employees of two prestigious
universities are behind bars this
morning accused of killing a Chicago
hairstylist and spending eight days on
the run
Windham Lapham is a microbiology
researcher at Northwestern Andrew Warren
works at Oxford University in England
they surrendered separately Friday in
Northern California their actions after
the stabbing death of Trenton Cornell
Duran Lowe are adding to the intrigue
surrounding the killing
Mireya Villarreal is in Dublin
California where Lapham is set to be
arraigned within hours good morning well
good morning in just a few hours Layden
will make his first court appearance
here in Alameda County California both
men are charged with murder they were on
the run for more than a week before
turning themselves in on Friday but now
we're learning they made a mysterious
stop in Wisconsin before driving into
California this is the Oakland
California police station where
university professor Wyndham Latham
turned himself in not far from where
Andrew Warren an Oxford University
employee also surrendered peacefully
Friday night I'm very excited Adam had
worked at Northwestern in Chicago since
2007 surveillance video captured him and
Warren leaving the building near
downtown on July 27 hours later
authorities got an anonymous call that a
crime had been committed in Latham's Ted
story apartment there police found the
body of Trenton Cornell Duran low he'd
been dead at least 12 hours Warren say
both men stabbed the victim police found
two knives nearby one with a broken
blade while they were on the run
investigators say Latham sent a video to
family and friends apologizing for his
involvement in the crime saying it was
the biggest mistake of my life and on
the day the body was discovered the two
drove some 80 miles northwest to Lake
Geneva Wisconsin where one made a
thousand dollar donation in cash to a
public library in the name of the victim
police say Latham had a relationship
with Cornell durán low while Warren had
arrived in the u.s. from Britain just
three days before the murder the reason
for the donation
remains a mystery Lathan's attorney says
he helped facilitate his client
surrender and he'll be asking for a
release on bail once he's extradited to
Chicago he's also asking the public
right now not to rush to judgment vlad
maria thanks